the way you know this is not going very
well for democrats
is that even the mainstream media
are trying to change course here nancy
pelosi was on talking to wolf blitzer on
cnn
and you know cnn just carries water for
democrats all the time
but on this issue of of the
current process wolf blitzer actually
cut her off
and nancy pelosi became so enraged she
accused them of shilling for the
republicans
even members of i haven't said that but
but even members of your own questions
even the members of your own caucus
madam speaker uh
want to accept this deal 1.8 trillion
dollars congressman roe connor
for example let me just let me just man
you know well
i assume you admire him he's a democrat
and he just said this he said people in
need can't wait
until february 1.8 trillion dollars
is significant and more than twice the
obama stimulus
make a deal put the ball in mcconnell
court so what do you say to roconna
what i say to you is i don't know why
you're always an apologist
and many of your colleagues apologize
for the republican position
rolcana that's nice that isn't what
we're going to do and nobody's waiting
till february
cnn they're apologists for the
republican position how can nancy pelosi
say that with a straight face
not even fox is apologizing and
defending republican positions anymore
much less cnn are you kidding me
are you kidding me how does she say that
because
occasionally they push back on democrats
and the democrats are not used to that
the thing you have to remember though is
that wolf blitzer and nancy pelosi want
the same thing they want more government
power and they want to spend
more and more money and they want
democrats to win elections
they want the same goals
but they're having a disagreement over
tactics when the media and the left
disagree
it's never over the end goal when the
media and conservatives disagree
it's over the goals it's over the vision
of the country it's over the politics
but the political system rather when the
media and the left elected democrats are
disagreeing
because obviously the media are the left
but when the media elected democrats are
disagreeing
it's over tactics not politics pelosi is
saying i'm going to play hardball with
trump and maybe we don't get a deal on
kovid
wolf blitz are saying damn it you need a
deal on kovid because we're losing this
election
so come on nancy get your act together
it's like a little spat between lovers
you know
they do want the same thing in the end
but there is disagreement now on the
left
about how they go about that i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you